[Music]
we absolutely loved Girl Meets World but
the show came with a bunch of
controversies and reports on cast
tensions today we'll explore some of the
most hidden secrets you never knew about
watch this video to the end to see how
the show accidentally changed rock
history if this is your first time here
then make sure you hit the like button
and subscribe to the things today we are
going to take a look at 10 dark secrets
Girl Meets World try to hide girl meets
cast tensions one of the things that
people liked most about Girl Meets World
was the positive relationship that the
show star seemed to have with each other
there were a lot of social media posts
showing them being friendly and goofing
off with one another but like with all
workplaces there were some tensions when
such time happened in 2017 when Uriah
Shelton who plays josh matthews offered
a bit of political opinion online he
said that he didn't think that there was
any need for feminism in modern society
now Rowan Blanchard who plays Riley
Matthews has been pretty outspoken about
that sort of thing in the past so that
might be why a lot of Girl Meets World
fans swarmed around Rowan's Instagram
account to tell her to do something
about it
Rowan told her social media followers
that what Uriah said wasn't worth a
minute of her time but it seems the
damage was done after the show was sadly
canceled Mariah tried to send Rowe in a
text message but it came back as
undelivered it seems that there was a
strong possibility that Rowan had
changed her cell number but had
neglected to tell you riah about it we
think perhaps your riah should have
thought before he spoke Girl Meets adult
humor while Girl Meets World is
predominantly a show for kids and
teenagers there are always going to be
some older viewers and the writers are
adults of course so we think that they
must have set themselves a kind of
challenge and that challenge was to see
if they could get more adult-oriented
jokes in the show for instance in the
episode girl meets boy Riley and her
classmates have to go to a public
library to do some research
Riley appears to be a bit shy about
speaking to Lucas but the librarian says
she should look in any book to figure
out what she should do next
any book apart from the one she's
reading that is and in another the
students are in art class it looks like
they are going to be drawing fruits when
Farkle barges in he says that people
shouldn't draw fruit but should get
ready to draw 48
pounds of nasty pretty gross right those
are just two of the more adult rated
jokes that the writers put into Girl
Meets World we think that if you like
the show you'll know more that you could
add to the list Girl Meets Economics
Girl Meets World was a show that like
its predecessor Boy Meets World was not
afraid to tackle some pretty big topics
one of the biggest topics that it dealt
with was that of money how we make it
and how we manage it in the episode a
girl meets crazy hats the pupils at John
Quincy Adams school had to split up into
two groups what Cory the teacher thought
that they should learn was about
different types of business so one half
was a company who was focused on making
money and the other half was a business
whose goal was to make people happy now
we think that that was the sort of thing
that could end up being a political
statement and we think that there isn't
much more divisive than politics right
the subject of money and finances raises
its head again in the episode girl meets
money this is the episode where we see
Farkle getting really stressed out
because his father has made a pretty
risky investment and he's scared that
his family is going to end up going
broke pretty dark stuff for what is
usually considered to be a kids show
don't you agree
girl meets coming out one of the best
things about Girl Meets World is that it
was willing to talk to kids about things
that a generation before would not have
been talked about and that level of
honesty seems to have made her way down
the cast of the show - that seems to be
especially true when it comes to Rowan
Blanchard who stars as Riley Matthews
back when she was 14 in early 2016
Riley made a big announcement on Twitter
she told her fans and the world at large
that she was a member of the lgbtq+
community that is a pretty big move for
anyone to make let alone a teenager she
was already amazing but what she did
took a lot of courage as a Disney
actress we all know Disney's not exactly
famous for being progressive with its
characters Rowan is also a role model
for young people who might struggle with
coming to terms with their sexuality but
it isn't just that while she came out
she also said that it was important that
the lgbtq+ teenagers were represented
however while we have seen characters
from the lgbtq+ community and other
shows we must admit that it left us kind
of disappointed
it's sad that Girl Meets World never
featured any LGBT+ characters on the
show Girl Meets high Hills a big part of
being a young
woman is finding your own fashion sense
one of the things we like about Girl
Meets World is that the characters
generally dress how you'd expect a young
woman to dress however that doesn't mean
that this shows costumes have been
without controversy in the episode Girl
Meets popular we see Riley dressing up
in attempt to be cool part of her outfit
is a pair of shiny red leather
high-heeled boots while Riley managed to
look pretty cool and pretty dorky at the
same time this attracted a fair amount
of controversy the argument went that
Riley as a middle school pupil should
not have been wearing high heels this
was because they would have been
uncomfortable and would have caused her
to possibly injure herself one
commentator pointed out that there was
no way that she would have been able to
walk as effortlessly as she did in the
episode especially if this was her first
time in heels
however the show's writers cottoned it
onto this and even had Riley referred to
it in the episode girl meets mr.
squirrels she said I wore high heels
once people have responded that's a
pretty cool way of owning the
controversy girl meets Feeny one of the
biggest issues that any successful TV
spin-off or sequel faces is the audience
wants to know what might have happened
to the original characters this was
certainly true in Girl Meets World while
the new generation of fans loved the new
generation of characters people who grew
up with Boy Meets World wanted to see
how the people from that show had turned
out that was perhaps most true of George
Feeny he was the teacher who Corian to
paying a turn to when they needed advice
back when they were growing up in the
1990s
yes Cory's role as a teacher in Girl
Meets World meant that he was sort of
like a surrogate for mr. Feeny's
character but for old school fans it
wasn't the same however mr. Feeny
appeared in Cory's imagination in the
pilot episode and while that was good
old school fans wanted more they got
what they wanted but they had to wait
until the second season when William
Daniels character returned anyone
watching the scenes he appeared in will
have found out exactly why George Feeny
has a place in the hearts of Boy Meets
World fans he certainly has a place in
ours Girl Meets topanga's fast for the
generation that grew up with Boy Meets
World Topanga was a major part of our
lives she was the main female character
in the show and Cody's girlfriend a big
part of why she made such a strong
impression on us is because of her
excellent portrayal by actress danielle
fishel when she returned she was married
to Cody and had
named Riley but we loved her just as
much if not more than before however
what you may not have known is that
danielle has written an autobiography
it's called normally this would be cause
for concern tells of calamity and
unrelenting awkwardness and it's pretty
good but did you know that she nearly
didn't play Topanga she said that it's
because she spoke too quickly at the
audition and ended up being cast in a
smaller part however when the original
first choice for Topanga didn't quite
cut it
Danielle redeemed herself and was cast
as the character that made her famous
she also dated NS YNC member Lance Bass
and she shared her first kiss both on
and off screen with Ben savage those are
just some of the pretty cool stories in
Danielle's book we didn't know about
them and we'll bet you didn't either
girl meets feminism sometimes actors can
represent their characters so well on
camera the world doesn't really know
what they're actually like in real life
however that's the thing that is
definitely not true about girl meets
world star Rowan Blanchard she is
clearly a very intelligent smart and
outspoken young lady and we like her all
the more for it something that she
hasn't shied away from is speaking out
as a feminist she has even said that she
prefers working for female directors
because they will understand what women
and girls want to see on the screen she
says that it's about the female gaze not
the male gaze Rowan also said she
started to identify as a true feminist
by watching the news and always keeping
up-to-date on current affairs she also
said that the Harry Potter actress Emma
Watson who also broke through at a young
age and is a modern-day feminist icon is
someone she looks up to her definition
of feminism is that it should get rid of
the structures that push people out to
the margins and she wants her work to
reflect this
although Disney is becoming more and
more progressive you have to admit that
it still lacks the gender equality
approach in the majority of its shows
girl meets cancellation they say that
all good things must come to an end even
so when it turned out that girl meets
world was being canceled by the Disney
Channel after just three season it came
as a pretty big blow we absolutely loved
the show and we have a feeling that you
did too well it looks like it might just
move stations it couldn't find a new
home but it wasn't just us the viewers
who were upset both the show's writers
and its stars were serious
saddened by the news both Rowan
Blanchard and Sabrina carpenter admitted
to shedding a few tears when they heard
the news the sad thing is we don't
really know why the show got given the
boot it was always going to be a big ask
for it to live up to the place in
popular culture that Boy Meets World had
but we think that it was getting there
and it wasn't as if it had terrible
ratings either it was a pretty popular
show we think that it certainly had the
sort of potential to go on and become
what Boy Meets World was back in the day
we are just sad that it never got the
opportunity and we wish you could be
brought back we think you do too girl
meets nostalgia the thing with spinning
off a show as beloved as Boy Meets World
is that you were always going to have
people who are cynical while a lot of
people will be excited about the new
thing they'll be nearly as many people
who want the original show to stay where
it was because they loved it so much and
when Girl Meets World was announced that
was something that happened one bizarre
fact that Girl Meets World had involved
a Canadian punk band called Topanga they
realized that their name would have a
totally different connotation so they
pretty much had to change it however
that was not before they posted an angry
message to their fans accusing the
Disney Channel of ruining their
childhoods however there is a happy
ending to that not only did Girl Meets
World become a success but Topanga the
band changed their name to pup toured
across the globe won awards for their
music and ended up being hailed by those
in the know as one of the best fans in
the world
so really everybody won but were there
any secrets and controversies that you
think we might have missed out let us
know and leave a comment and that's all
for 10 dark secrets Girl Meets World
tried to hide we hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to the things
[Music]